et pour en parler nous sommes avec
christian grolier secrétaire général fo
fonction publique bonjour et merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
le projet de loi sur la réforme des
retraites a donc débuté son parcours à
l'assemblée nationale est ce que le
gouvernement peut encore reculer selon
vous oui on le souhaite sinon d'abord
nous ferions pas encore une journée de
mobilisation aujourd'hui et dans les
jours qui viennent
donc oui on pense que le gouvernement
doit reculer d'ailleurs la meilleure
preuve c'est de constater dans votre
journal que tous les interlocuteurs que
ce soit les interlocuteurs syndicaux
mais aussi du côté des députés du côté
du conseil d'état peut être demain du
conseil constitutionnel tout le monde
reconnaît que cette réforme est bâclé
n'est pas financé et quelque part toute
façon sera une réforme en défaveur des
salariés dont je crois que si le
gouvernement avait un petit peu le sens
de l'intérêt général pour une fois ils
reculeraient sur cette réforme
le conseil d'état qui en ont publié
vendredi un avis particulièrement
critique il regrette de ne pas avoir eu
le temps de garantir au mieux la
sécurité juridique du projet de réforme
ce sont les termes c'est la plus haute
juridiction administrative française
critiquent le recours notamment à 29
ordonnance qui selon lui font perdre la
visibilité d'ensemble elle pointe
cette administration les projections
financières lacunaire ça va dans le sens
de ce que voulait non c'est finalement
aujourd'hui
oui totalement on n'arrête pas de
dénoncer le fait que toutes les
simulations qui ont été apportées par le
gouvernement
son faust ou sont monté de telle manière
quand on dit que les simulations sont
faites sur un âge de départ à 65 ans
c'est quand même assez étonnant
on nous dit on garde de l'âge
d'ouverture des droits à 62 ans y aurait
peut-être un âge pivot à 64 ans et on
nous fait des simulations de 65 ans donc
il faut être un petit peu crédible dans
ce qu'on fait tout le monde sait que les
simulations ne sont pas réalistes et en
particulier puisque l'on parle des
ordonnances les fonctionnaires que je
représente 100 énormément concernés par
les ordonnances et personne aujourd'hui
n'est capable de dire comment se
réintégrer les primes pour ce cas non
pas et y compris coupe pour ceux qui en
ont comment le seraient calculées sur la
durée de la carrière
donc cette réforme elle n'est pas
construite elle n'est pas financée et
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qu'elle n'est
pas capable d'être expliquée par le
gouvernement et que les français ne la
comprennent pas
l'idée de départ du gouvernement c'était
mettre en place un système de retraite
universel avec les mêmes droits pour
tous
vous faites allusion à l'instant aux
ordonnances
est ce qu'on peut encore parler d'un
système universel ce qu'il n'y a pas de
plus en plus de dérogations fait à
différents corps de métier et comment
est ce que vous les voyez c'est des
relations
vous avez raison sur 10 à un système
universel tout le monde pareil on voit
bien que ce ne sera pas le cas il ya des
dérogations déjà sur les générations
on nous dirait la génération de 75 pour
une majorité de personnel ou de salariés
pour d'autres générations notamment les
forces de sécurité se serait génération
maintenant on nous dit que pour certains
il y aurait des primes supplémentaires
et pas pour d'autres
enfin on le voit les dérogations
pleuvent de tous les côtés donc ce
régime universel il n'a pas de sens je
crois qu'il faut dire le fond de la
réforme le fond de la réforme ce n'est
pas le régime universel pour tout le
monde le fond de la réforme s'est passé
d'un système par répartition un système
où il y aurait un socle minimal de
pension très faible et obliger ceux qui
ont les moyens de le faire aller vers la
capitalisation et les fonds de pension
ou problème c'est que ceux qui auront
pas l'argent pour le faire auront tous
les petites retraites à la conférence de
financement s'ouvre demain l'objectif on
le rappelle c'est de trouver avant fin
avril les moyens de garantir à l'
équilibre financier qui est voulu par
exécutif ce que votre syndicat il
participera quelle est la position
aujourd'hui d'infos sur ce point la
position de fo au sens large c'est de
participer tous les instants on ne
pourra porter nos revendications donc
évidemment dans cette première
conférence nous y participeront après la
vraie question c'est quelle sera
j'allais dire la capacité de les battre
déjà cette conférence est figé par
l'article 56 bis du projet de loi qui
dit qu'on ne peut parler que de certains
points et en particulier on ne pourrait
pas parler des recettes
il faut qu'on puisse parler des recettes
si c'est pour nous dire vous venez à la
conférence et vous ne parlerez que de
l'âge pour l'augmenter ou de la durée de
cotisation pour le monter il est évident
que notre présence sera peut-être pas de
longue durée mais espérons que pour une
fois le gouvernement aura un peu le sens
du consensus et surtout sera nous
écouter on a des propositions sur
l'emploi des seniors sur les cotisations
sur les exonérations de cotisations il
ya des moyens de trouver des recettes le
gouvernement veut donc trouver 12
milliards d'euros d'ici à 2027 pour
équilibrer l'actuel régime
les retraites quelle solution est ce que
vous proposez un chien il faut pour
relever ce défi d'abord ce qu'on
souhaite c'est qu'on puisse avoir une
conversation
j'allais à la plus équilibrée possible
avec le patronat parce que le patronat
aujourd'hui dis clairement nous on ne
leur ait augmenté dans le coût du
travail
ça paraît quand même assez
extraordinaire en section augmenter les
cotisations de 1%
les recettes seraient suffisants
suffisante pour maintenir les régimes
des retraites à l' équilibre dont nous
on dit regardons les choses tout se
passe aussi avec l'emploi il faut
baisser le niveau du chômage il faut
continuer l'emploi des seniors ce n'est
quand même pas très sérieux de dire
qu'on va faire travailler des gens
jusqu'à 64 65 ans alors qu'on sait
qu'aujourd'hui plus de la moitié des
salariés quand ils arrivent à l'âge de
la retraite sont déjà sans emploi donc
il faut augmenter l'emploi des seniors
tout ça c est même des recettes ça amène
des cotisations et puis il faut qu'on
puisse mettre sur la table
l'augmentation des cotisations
patronales salariat et regarder des
entreprises qui ont été exonérés de
cotisations voir ce que ça donne en
terme d'emplois ici ça a rien donné
il faut qu'on va mettre en cause
certaines moyens pour financer les
retraites
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment
aujourd'hui que le gouvernement fait
peser sur les organisations syndicales
la responsabilité du financement du
système des retraites puisque en gros
edouard philippe l'a dit encore quelques
quelques semaines il y à cette
conférence de financement les
organisations syndicales sont invités à
faire des propositions
sans cela ce si elle n'arrive pas à se
mettre d'accord alors c'est l'exécutif
qui tranchera pour tout vous dire je
crains que ce soit un marché de dupes
parce que la conférence de financement
ne fait que vous revenir sur des
multiples revendications de toutes les
organisations syndicales et le
gouvernement nous a fait déjà le même
mauvais couleurs de l'assurance chômage
en nous disant si vous ne trouvez pas de
compromis entre les organisations
salariales et patronales
on reprendra la mer est là aujourd'hui
on nous dit trouver un compromis sans
pouvoir parler de recettes et en sachant
que d'ores et déjà notamment le medef et
le patronat sont favorables à la réforme
je crains que ce soit une conférence
pour rien en tout cas nous irons porter
nos revendications
si on part en surface avec l attention
merci beaucoup d'être a priori elle
répondre à nos questions christian
grolier secrétaire général fo elle
fonction publique